there you go here with reaction Fox News
contributor Jonathan Turley you know
Jonathan I you listen to him saying oh
so many Americans are disappointed he
did that he
'd be disappointed and to feel like they
were abandoned by promising something
that was completely inappropriate and he
knew it with this new statement he made
and you've got a great column out there
and you've been very very direct about
your opinion about what he was doing
here where do you think this does go for
now and will he be successful in some
other fashion
well this new path is designed to avoid
the Constitutional path right what he's
supposed to do is just go to Congress
he's supposed to go to Congress and say
everyone wants this it's a great idea
and get it passed but he knows it won't
pass because there is formidable
opposition to the concept of law of loan
forgiveness so this this new path is
like going from DC to New York by way of
La I mean it is you know there's a very
obvious place for him to go it's just
down the street from the White House but
instead he's going to try to use uh this
Higher Education Act Now what's
interesting about that is I don't think
it can get him where he needs to go
first of all this was rejected believe
it or not the heroes Act was viewed as
the better path before so they're now
going to plan B with the statute they
rejected in favor of the heroes act
which in my view was just face racially
absurd because it was It was obviously
not the intent of Congress and that
rather short act uh benefiting veterans
that this could be done through that
language uh but the problem that he's
going to have is is threefold first uh
this New Path involves an act that is
more limited so there's it is very
specific as to what type of loans could
be forgiven it would not cover the scope
of the current plan second he's got to
go through rule making well what what it
does do though it's going to take time
doesn't it yes well exactly right this
allows them to keep up this rhetoric and
to maintain the promises and then to
continually point to the Republicans or
the conservatives as as mean bigots
while they know it's it's just theater
in As Americans it's theater is one
thing politically right but when you're
you know talking to the American people
and depressing them and disappointing
them and making them look at their
neighbor funny that's a whole different
uh ball game isn't it
well it is sort of funny you sell
someone a fake gold watch and then you
get them to to be angry that it's not
gold involving some third party I mean
he's the one that sold you the watch and
during in the whole time many of us were
saying look this is not going to work
but because they're picking this other
act it's likely to go through the next
election they'll be able to campaign on
this issue and I my guess is that a lot
of these students are going to feel more
victims than Chumps you know they're
gonna they're gonna feel like they had
real money that was taken away from them
by this court all the court is saying is
there's a place you go for money in our
constitutional system it's just down the
block from where you live
and you know of course they not only is
it about targeting Republicans but the
rhetoric about the the court itself has
come back as though they didn't learn
anything when it came to the reaction
after the Dobbs decision but they're
just gonna double down on that it would
seem
yeah I agree Tammy and it's really
distressing to hear this uh inflammatory
rhetoric come back these are justices by
the way on the conservative end of the
court that delivered a number of
Victories to the white Administration
right including a huge Victory where
they upheld uh his the the immigration
policies of the president
um they have not hesitated to vote for
the president when law and the
Constitution was on his side it wasn't
on his side here he was openly
circumventing Congress and using this
attenuated argument involving this this
act and they were rightfully uh you know
going to come down on the side of the
Constitution but you now have the same
group of Court Packers saying you know
we've got to get rid of the court or
expand the court and these these types
of attacks these justices are trying to
get it right and I think that they got a
lot right this week yeah and they also
handed down a major Free Speech Victory
today and that that in that case is
going to resonate for decades it's a
huge victory for free it will this is
it's very good news but it is it's
rather amusing that when it's a decision
that Democrats like suddenly the Court's
not evil and then when it's a decision
they don't like Suddenly It's evil and
it has to go they're like Toddlers and
they just can't they just don't get it
Jonathan Turley great job of course as
always thank you sir for joining me hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else